It is almost all of the above.
jQuery does add a few kilobytes to the size of your pages, so
it will add a minute amount of time to your page loads.
But, given all of the syntactical sugar you gain,
most developers are more than happy to add it to their Web sites.
On a personal note, I want to add that while I was making this class,
my opinion about jQuery actually changed a little bit.
I generally tend to use just plain old JavaScript to do
DOM manipulation because I don't want to add the extra kilobytes to my pages.
But honestly, after doing the research in developing this class and
spending more and more and more time with jQuery, it really is pretty awesome.
So, I'm going to go ahead and draw a smiley face here.
It's an ugly smiley face, but that's how I'm feeling right now.
So, good job for finishing, guys.